corse la langue se parlent à la maison à
la télé montagnat dans les débats
politiques mais pas les mambas toral
cause à libé en revanche la langue n'est
pas reconnu par l'état français elle
n'est pas officielle et ça ça ne
convient pas à une partie de la
population insulaire et pour le corps
sur le français disons donc co
officialité co officialité ou bien la
parité entre le corps et le français en
pratique cela veut dire que les deux
langues seraient sur les documents
officiels et parler dans les
administrations la revendication date
d'au moins 30 ans qui lie à ici une
communauté une communauté qui vit qui a
une langue une culture et qui demande à
ce que cette langue et les moyens de
vivre et pour nous le moyen principal
c'est la reconnaissance officielle et la
co officialité les élus de l'assemblée
de corse on débatte en 1989
je me félicite de la tenue de cette
réunion
et vous en complément pas de texte
adopté même si l'idée gagne du terrain
en corse
mais qu'importe en 1992 l'état brise
toute éventualité de qu'officialiser en
ajoutant un alinéa dans l'article 2 de
la constitution la langue de la
république est le français
cette modification l'euro député
nationaliste max simeoni là déplore il
faudra romancier un statut officiel de
la langue régionale
c'est incompatible et surtout à la
profit shalit et il est plus question de
refi shalit et ça sera
anticonstitutionnelle la co officialité
anticonstitutionnelle pour autant la
mobilisation se prépare syndicats
d'étudiants nationalistes en première
ligne
peu à peu la co officialité gagne des
partisans de tous bords au delà des
nationalistes
jusqu'à ce jour de 2013 où l'assemblée
de corse vente en faveur de la parité
entre les deux langues
le texte proposé par la majorité de
gauche a été approuvé par 36 des 50 et
en élus on va attendre
bien évidemment la position de l'état et
savoir si l'etat sera réceptif à cette
demande majoritaire de l'assemblée de
corse négatif répond le ministre de
l'intérieur en visite sur l'île on ne
peut pas changer la constitution depuis
une assemblée territoriale
il n'y a qu'une seule langue officielle
dans la république c'est le français
en 2015 les corses ont porté le tandem
nationaliste simeoni talamoni à la tête
de l'assemblée de corse en 2017
trois des quatre députés de l'île sont
aussi issus des rangs des nationalistes
tous font un travail de lobby pour faire
modifier la constitution
mais rien n'y fait l'état reste fermé
aux revendications des élus corses
[Musique]